ce qui nous semble très très frappant
c'est comment se forment les unanimité
en termes de politique économique je
suis ça depuis presque cinquante ans
pour vous avouer et je suis toujours
surpris qu face à des situations
complexes à l'origine il ya des débats
par exemple entre les interventionnistes
et les céfécistes mais du fait de
l'étroitesse de l'élite si vous voulez
qu'il entre lesquels se définit les
paradigmes admis brutalement convergent
vers une sorte de dock ça tout le monde
se met à imaginer désinflation
compétitive compétitive et on a la même
analyse qui se développent et cette
analyse tient par un consensus si vous
voulez de milieu c'est à dire que tout
le monde est incertain et on imagine que
le ce qui s'est dégagé comme opinion est
très robuste
or on s'aperçoit que c'est presque une
convention sociale est là ce qui est
touchant 1 l'an dernier à la même époque
il n'avait pas il n'avait pas un
milliard a donné à l'hôpital parce que
c'était la contrainte budgétaire c'était
un largeur gratuit et vous avez très
bien que comme la menace d'effondrement
économique est tout à fait peu présent
le système d'interprétation des
banquiers centraux des mises des
finances changer brutalement 10 mai à la
monnaie c'est une monnaie fiduciaire
pour autant que nous ayons la confiance
et le refinancement des banques
centrales
ce crédit peut parfaitement alimenté une
reprise y voit un nouveau jeu brutal
basculement des paradigmes de la doxa
économique parce qu'elle était très
fragile el had
elle a tenu très très très longtemps des
contraintes et alors tout le discours
des contraintes économiques disparaît
parce que tout dépend des circonstances
et à nouveau l'arrêt ce qui est tout à
fait intéressante
les économies ce rêve d'un monde où il y
aurait plus d'histoire et là on les
appelle à la modestie
attention l'histoire survient et vous
n'êtes pas prêt à l'analyser et à
fournir des outils de politique
économique correspondants et c'est ça la
grande le grand appel à la modestie des
économistes faites attention vous avez
vous êtes conviés façade événements
historiques qui n'ont pas de précédent
soyez imaginatifs et 1
[Musique]